Let's find out what the right answers are.
Fibonacci of 6 = 8.
Well, if N is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
We said that Fibonacci of N was 1, 1, 2, 3, 5, 8.
It does look like Fibonacci of 6 = 8. Great!
Is Fibonacci of N always < or = N + 1?
Well, 1 is < or = to 2. 2 is < or = 3.
1 < or = 1. 5 < or = 8.
This is certainly true.
The Fibonacci sequence is strictly nondecreasing.
It either stays the same or gets bigger.
This next one was a bit of a ringer--a bit of a trick.
The vast majority of the time, almost always, albeit finitely often,
Fibonacci of N is strictly > than Fibonacci of N + 1, except right here at the start
when Fibonacci of 1 and Fibonacci of 2 are both 1, so they're = rather than <.
So no dice there.
Is Fibonacci of 20 > 1000?
Yes. The sequence grows super fast.
Let's just go check.
I'll just write out the definition of Fibonacci right here.
I'm declaring a procedure called fibo. It takes an argument n.
Here's our base case: if n < or = to 2, return 1.
Otherwise, we call ourselves recursively 2 times.
And the answer is 6,765. Wow! That's immense.
Notably, it's bigger than the 1000 we were asking about.
True!